(ambient music)
- [Narrator] Fabrice Schnöller
is an engineer, biologist,
and founder of the DAREWIN Project.
His goal is to record and analyze
sperm whale vocalizations.
Sperm whales communicate using
a series of complex clicking.
Some clicks are as short as
a thousandth of a second.
Fabrice's objective is to
gather as many recordings of the
whales as possible, to figure
out if that language exists.
But sperm whales are not the
easiest animals to get close to.
By free-diving - diving on
a single breath of air -
Fabrice is able to get
incredibly close to the whales.
(ambient music)
It's through these intimate interactions
that Fabrice is able to capture
the recordings he needs to one day
unlock the secret of their communication.